north carolina just in general man it
feels like there's just a dope wave and
energy coming out of the state out of
the carolinas in general what do you
think like special about what's coming
out of your region at the moment um that
everybody don't sound like each other i
think that's i think that's the
beautiful part about it like we don't
have a
distinct sound i feel like uh and i feel
like that's fire because you see how
many
um
how many different types of artists come
out of either the city or the state
right so i think that's just fine as
hell yeah because like you know you got
like obviously coal guys like yourself
and then you got the baby who's also a
lyrical monster and then you got stoner
for vegas who's doing like
you know street [ __ ] and so i just think
there's like a dope diverse like
roster of guys that are coming out the
city right now it's all the same [ __ ] uh
really you know what i'm saying like
it's all the same [ __ ] but like
different genres different everybody
talk about it differently